la galerie des sablons situé à plaisir
est en plein chantier la structure est
en train de subir un profond lifting
pour devenir le centre baptisé open sky
une structure de 38 mille mètres carrés
avec une quarantaine de magasins des
restaurants et un multiplexe d'une
dizaine de salles pour opérer cette mue
spectaculaire tout sera démoli pour être
reconstruit ça fait longtemps que cet
ensemble commercial qui est comme on dit
dans son jus c'est à dire qui date des
années 80 et est je dirais
obsolète donc le projet de centres tels
que gianni ranallo l'architecte l'a
dessinée va d'un seul coup amener de la
modernité de l' architecture dans cette
partie de la zone qui en avaient besoin
en parallèle des travaux les
responsables s'activent pour attirer des
enseignes
les dirigeants ont annoncé la semaine
dernière la venue de la marque
irlandaise prix marque la structure
permettra d'attirer une clientèle jeune
la marque a été créée en 1969 et ne
compte que neuf magasins en france ce
sera certainement la plus grande surface
du futur centre et ça va être clairement
pour nous une locomotive très importante
paris marque est une enseigne qui est
relativement nouvelle en france mais qui
s'implantent rapidement et qui se
développe beaucoup dans pour nous c'est
bien sûr un atout
pour nous et pour open sky c'est bien
sûr un atout important pour faire son
shopping dans cette boutique il faudra
être patient l'inauguration est
programmée pour le 1er semestre 2010 9